what loyalty is because they think that
a man being loyal to them is never
cheating right but a man he used a
scenario of someone who likes apples if
a man always eats apples doesn't mean
he's low to Apples the man that's loyal
to Apples eats apples all the time and
then eats a strawberry but always comes
back to Apples he eats a banana but
always comes back to Apples and that is
what loyalty is loyalty means if if
there's no if there's no alternative I
have no choice but to be loyal to you
and loyalty to a man the way men see it
is like but I'm always coming back to
you that means I'm I don't care about
these other it's just something that was
kind of throw away
but if I'm always coming back to you
that's what loyalty is I have a question
um for you Sarah and actually both both
of you too
um when do you think a man becomes
disloyal
so if he if so if he okay so if he he's
sleeping with other girls that doesn't
automatically mean he's disloyal is he
disloyal if like because don't you think
guys on some level ever developed
feelings for the side chick I've heard
stories where like side chicks get
written into the wills they're like
stuff like that yeah yeah yeah so so
when does it become disloyal when he
like you said like when he takes his
finances and his time and gives it to
somebody else he's disloyal so if he has
like if I write my if I had like a
mistress okay right and I'm married and
I've got and I write her into my will
that's disloyalty is it disloyalty if he
has a whole side chick
in what sense what do you mean okay so I
I don't know I think no I think that is
this little because he's given her time
and energy that he could be given to his
wife
um a man that's a man that has I don't
know a couple of one night stands with I
don't know some random chick and comes
back to his wife as a man I don't think
that's but he's dislowing his energy to
someone else yeah but it's like it's
throwaway a man will have sex with a
hole in the world
if a guy has a side chick where it's
just like easier to use her right I'm
just curious when guys like variety as
well yeah so so but if he has like a
side chick that it's just like easier to
go to her because sex is hard for men to
get and if he has one you might want to
retain it if he's looking to cheat right
and I just wonder like when is exactly
the line like does he have feelings me
personally I've never had it me
personally I've never had a side chance
that's just me personally I've never had
this I know someone that has I know
somebody hasn't and I know that them
having that side chick took so much time
and effort and also resources out of
them and I was like bro I ain't got time
for that unless unless I would say that
man was dislike of course but unless
that woman is part of the
conglomerate okay right I've always said
if you want two women they need to know
about each other or streaming they need
to know about each other and they need
to know that this is what what it is but
if you're running around on the side and
it's like you're taking all and you have
to hide and you have to put your phone
down and all this kind of stuff and the
woman can't know
that's not a whole nother relationship
bro like it's just disloyalty now see I
think um there's levels to it in it so
like
if like guys can just trip and fall into
[ __ ] it happens by accident
you can work past that I feel like but
then obviously when you're actually
having a whole nother relationship on
the side that's mad because who's got
time for that and then that is
essentially like you're doing what the
woman like what you were classes the
woman is being like like this law
because you're investing time anymore
yeah and when does it become a
relationship like how often does he have
to see her for it to become a
relationship if you're banging the same
life it's more than once then it's like
so if he hooked up with her twice in a
year that's probably not disloyalty so
it's it's right so see it has to be a
level of how often it's this law but I'd
say once you get into the realm of like
your texting every day you're hiding
messages you're deleting stuff yeah when
you start being sneaky yeah then yeah
because you're constantly lying to your
partner at that point like
I don't know whether it's just me but I
know of older West Indian couples where
happily married man
happily married woman on the outside the
wife knows about her they know about
each other and they want to class as
disloyal but that's why it's nobody but
she's part of the conglomerate
she's part of the arrangement you've got
the house to replace our children and
she's part of the Arena I remember going
out somewhere and every time I went out
I always saw this older woman don't look
at me and I remember saying to him
something about your wife or something
about your husband that's not my husband
and I thought but I've seen you use it
all together and she was so adamant and
angry that I called
her his wife but I'd seen you together
for like 10 years yeah and then when I
said to someone who is she like you know
I used to work with a guy I thought that
was his wife I used to work with him and
I thought who's that woman that goes no
no this is not his wife and then we went
to an official function and then you say
as well then I saw the wife and the wife
just like sort of rolls out on the
official function she's got the big
house you know the kids of raised she's
there with the grandchildren their
husband has got two keys for two houses
do you know what to his home and the
women they don't argue they don't see
each other because she's smart she's
she's partly around it's not seen as
dislikely
those women have escaped The Matrix
they're getting they're getting the the
full benefits
it's not mine because she's got the kids
she's got the pension she's got a house
and she hasn't got that everything
everything you wanted you're getting and
once you've started to detach from this
idea of owning people it's not that deep
if you understand that it's not a worse
thing that can happen at your mind
speaking somebody else who's attracted
to someone that you're so secure in what
you like it don't mean nothing and more
time another thing that I've also
realized with this whole cheating thing
women aren't busy enough you've got too
much time on your hands to be coming to
do digging up like if you had your own
[ __ ] you would not even be concerning
yourself what you're quote unquote
management because you're getting taken
care of that's what another thing I
wanted to point out but yeah um I have a
side chick I've told Auntie this before
I have a side chick story
um I know someone that was like very
Catholic so she was like the most the
most one of the most Catholic people
I've ever met like she she believes in
hell she believes in heaven like she
went to church every day like that sort
of thing she was married to someone
um for I don't know 50 years total but
about like 20 30 years in the the her
husband had an affair with someone at
work and he actually left the family to
go to the side chick he left his family
and she prayed to God for a solution she
said God like she she didn't believe in
divorce so she's like please bring him
back together she believed that like
salvation for her husband like wouldn't
be offered if he really left and he
really committed adultery and didn't
come back so she prayed to God for a
solution the side chick died
and he came home
I remember my late Godfather and he was
like he was one of the best Godfather
ever was to sit there and chat he was
happily married he had his children from
his wife
and when he died and she found his will
he had a whole other family out there
and he had she didn't know about she
didn't lose any money she didn't lose
any house they had properties in
Barbados that properties here
but he had this whole other family that
and they had a house and he had children
and the wife was really upset and I
thought but you only found out when he
died you know it didn't bother you it
didn't take away she didn't notice or
anything like that and it was still one
lies he and he
everybody was happy when he'd everybody
was well taken care of when he died his
other family and my aunt and he was a
fantastic man but I don't know how he
kept it secret because he had a whole
other family going on and nobody knew
about it and he just went to work it was
always a hard worker so over time I
think that's where the overtime went the
overtime went there none of the women
suffered nobody suffered none the family
suffer Diva as many you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible